the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today I want to talk a little bit about
controlling our designing control
systems this will finish up our
discussions of signals and systems let
me then just briefly review where we are
hopefully this might help you also to
fur perspective with regard to thinking
about the exam tonight we've looked at a
bunch of different kinds of
representations for discrete-time
systems the easiest most concise method
we looked at was the representation
using a difference equation that's
mathematically as concise as you can get
but it doesn't tell you important things
like who's the input and who's the
output and what are all the different
ways that you can get through the system
from input to output so for that
question block diagrams are nice block
diagrams are graphical it makes it very
easy to see when there is for example a
cyclic path through the through the
network but they're graphic they're not
nearly so concise those difference
equations so then we went on to
operators operators are just as concise
as difference equations but they contain
additional information because the
operators have an implicit argument so
there's an input which is the argument
to the operator and there's an output
which is the output of the operator so
you can tell who is the input and who is
the output so that's good that sort of
combines the strengths of difference
equations and block diagrams you end up
with a concise representation that has
complete information about the signal
flow paths furthermore you can analyze
the operators by using polynomial
mathematics and that gives rise to the
notion of a system functional and that's
a very nice closure because that
represents an abstraction that lets us
think about a whole system as though it
were just one part
one thing one Operator so we use that
structure then all of those
representations to try to learn about
feedback and first off in the block
diagram it's very easy to see that
anytime you have feedback feedback so
enormous ly powerful that we want to use
it in design but you can see immediately
from the structure of the block diagram
that if you have feedback then you have
cycles why is that interesting well
that's interesting because if you have
cycles then even transient inputs can
generate persistent outputs so that's a
kind of behavior that we would like to
understand so from the nature of
feedback it generates cycles from the
nature of cycles it generates persistent
responses even if there's no implant and
we saw that we could characterize those
by thinking about those responses for
one part at a time and those parts we
thought of as poles and the responses to
a single pole we called modes so we
thought through a way of decomposing the
responses of a complicated system in
terms of the response in terms of a
number of additive components that are
based on polls polls are just the base
of a geometric sequence so today then
what I want to do is use that framework
to think about design how would you
optimize the design of a controller so
looking back to where we've been way
back in lab for ancient history we
looked at how you could program the
robot to approach a wall and we saw that
depending on how you set up that system
you could get very different
performances and what we'd like to do is
have a way that we can design for
performance without actually building it
the kind of thing that we built in the
lab lab before was so easy that building
it to the terminus behaviors was not a
bad problem but in general if you were
building a 777
there's more than one Pole
and you wouldn't necessarily want to
test drive all over the bad
configurations so we'd like to be able
to understand that kind of a problem
analytically we'd like to be able to
analyze it so using the different
representations you can generate a very
concise representation just thinking in
terms of difference equations you all
did this in lab 4 and you get a single
difference equation that tells you in
principle everything there is that you
could know but not in a form that's very
easy to analyze it's a bit better if you
translate the difference equation into a
block diagram because now you can see
that this system of equations has in
fact two feedback loops in it two cycles
two things that might potentially
generate persistent responses to
transient signals which could then
degrade performance if the transient
signal lasts ten years it might be a bad
controller if the f77 if the 777 hits
turbulence and never stabilizes right
that would be bad if small disturbances
got bigger with time that might be bad
right so we can see that this simple
controller described by these difference
equations has the potential to do that
sort of stuff and we'd like to
understand when when does it the easiest
way to think about analyzing this is to
think about focus first on the inner
loop and ask the question what's the
functional representation for that box
which we would call an accumulator this
box this thing accumulates at its output
the sum of all the things that ever came
in so we call it an accumulator so
what's the functional representation of
an accumulator well we just do
polynomial math easy right so we can
recognize from the block diagram that
the signal Y could be constructed by
applying our to W but we can also see in
the block diagram that W
is the sum of x and y and then if we
take the left hand side and the right
hand side of this double equation we get
something that involves just x and y
which we can solve for the ratio Y over
X which then says that the ratio is R
over 1 minus R that's a functional
representation for the effect of the
accumulation that's also something that
comes up so frequently in in the design
of control systems that we give it a
name we call this Black's equation and
it's especially useful to avoid these
little trivial steps in algebra to just
jump to the answer so let's see that
everybody's following me figure out the
the equation for this box is the thing
that we will call blocks at the black's
equation it's not mysterious it's
something that you could derive so
derive it figure out the functional form
for the system that goes from X to Y and
figure out which of these forms is
correct 1 through 4 or 5 if none of the
above applies so take 30 seconds figure
out the answer I'm going to ask you to
raise your hand you're free to talk to
your neighbors
okay so everybody raise your hands tell
me what the right answer is okay
wonderful it's about 95 percent you know
it's about 100 percent correct out of
about 95 percent participation so the
answer you can form just like we did
before no particular tricks using simple
algebra simple algebra you get F over 1
minus FG
the thing I want you to recognize is
kind of a graphical way of thinking
about that and you can just memorize
that over 1 minus FG and that's fine
but there's some interesting things that
a designer thinks about the this this
functional form is f that's the forward
gain that's the game through the system
starting at the input and going directly
to the output so this form says that the
closed loop gain the loop that happened
they the system functional that results
when the loop is closed is just the
forward gain F divided by 1 minus the
loop gain the loop gain is the product
around the loop once so that's just a
convenient way of thinking about it
anytime you have a feedback system of
this type you can think about the closed
loop response as being the forward path
F divided by 1 minus the loop gain FG so
the answer was 1 and generally we'll see
two different ways of representing this
system sometimes we'll represent it with
the plus as we did with the accumulator
many times we'll represent it with a -
that's the way we think about control
problems we put in the minus because we
like to think about the controller as
trying to make something go to zero so
when you take the difference that gives
us an error signal and then we can think
about the controller being the thing
that drives that error to zero but
however you think about it there's two
forms that are very closely related they
really differ by just the minus sign
which you could think of as just
multiplying G so it's sort of like the
right hand side is just a minus g
plugged in to the left hand side so then
the way you use this idea you think
about the block diagram and you say okay
I can replace this thing with an E
system which is our over 1 minus R and
then repeat so the R over 1 minus R
means that if you think about blacks
equation now for this Lu you think about
the forward gain K minus T R over 1
minus R that's this divided by 1 plus
the loop gain so 1 plus and the loop
gain well this the wire down here just
has a gain of 1 so the loop gain and
floor regain are the same thing so you
get this kind of expression which
simplifies to this there's two things I
want you to see free about this first
off I want you to see that even though
the simple-minded way of plugging in
said that we should have got a quotient
of quotients and over dear Ranma over D
it's simplified to a single ratio if you
have if you design a system out of just
adders games and delays that will always
be true there's a closure it will always
be the case that the functional that
represents a system of that form will
always have the property that it's a
polynomial in R divided by another
polynomial in R that's just way
polynomials work the other thing is that
you can now start to interpret what the
behavior this could could represent in a
simpler form than thinking about this so
this kind of a representation that leads
to intuition about what the behavior
should be is very helpful when you're
thinking about design and in particular
this particular thing says that if we
think about this thing as the way if we
think about a simpler system that could
generate that same response we can
generate some intuition for where we
would like how we would like to set the
parameter K so in particular this system
this system functional which we
generated for this system could equally
apply to that system
exactly
so there's a numerator which I've
represented here there's a numerator
which has an R in it and has a minus KT
in it I'm gonna for reasons that you see
in a minute I'm gonna call something P
naught because it's the pole so the
numerator I've represented here and this
denominator has this form and I wrote it
that way because this is the canonical
form for the way of thinking about a
pole so what I've showed is that even
though this was a more complicated
system you can think about it as the
Cascade of a delay a game and a pole the
game the pole can be calculated from the
game the pole is the multiplier for R so
the pole is 1 plus KT so if I were to
choose KT to be minus 0.2 then the pole
would be at 0.8 if the pole is at 0.8
then the mode the natural response to
the pole would have the poor P to the N
they always have the form geometric P to
the N so look I point eight to the N
because of the pre multiplier of 1 minus
P naught the whole thing gets multiplied
by 0.2 and because of the delay the
whole thing gets shifted to the right
the important thing is that by thinking
about manipulating this as an operator
we can recognize and simplify the form
of the behavior that gives us an
intuitive grasp over how to best choose
KT every now the behaviors that we're
interested in are not always unit sample
responses we do you in a sample
responses because they're the easiest
possible thing we could think of right a
unit sample is the simplest nonzero
signal
right a unit sample is the signal that
is different from zero in exactly one
place the easiest possible place zero
and it has it's easy as possible non
zero value one so we felt this on the
unit sample signal because it's the
easiest possible signal we could think
about but when we're thinking about
behaviors were often thinking about
other things often we'll think about the
step response here I've Ellis trated the
way you would measure a step response as
step response is what would happen if
the output were initially zero if we
were at rest and suddenly we turned on a
signal that was constant at one so that
would happen in the in the robot case if
we started the robot close to the wall
at Raths near zero so that the output is
close to zero so the output signal is
close to 0 but the desired input was a
meter behind then that would be an input
signal that started at time equal zero
equal to 1 and persisted forever at 1
and the result then would be what we
call the step response the step response
is typically easier to measure in the
lab than is the unit sample response so
we use the unit sample response when
we're thinking analytically what we're
doing calculations and we use the SEP
response when we're in the lab trying to
measure something and the whole theory
wouldn't be very useful if there weren't
a close relationship between those two
things and this diagram illustrates the
relationship if we think about a system
H for which we would like to find the
step response the step response of that
system is what would the system do if
you put the unit step into the system
I've represented the unit step here is U
of M U of n the signal that is 0 for n
less than 0 and 1 for n bigger than or
equal to 0 is just the accumulation of
the Delta function the
sample so this system the cascade of an
accumulator with H would measure the
step response of H if it were driven
with the unit sample signal because of
the properties of polynomials and
because block diagrams follow the rules
for polynomials we can flip these
whatever the system's both start at rest
and if we flip those we get a different
interpretation what this says is that if
you were to take H and stimulate it with
the unit sample you would get H little H
which we would call the unit sample
response because it's the response to
the system when the input is you an
example so if you measured H with the
unit sample rather than with a unit step
you would get the unit sample response
from which you could generate the step
response by running it through an
accumulator so what that says is there's
a close association there's a close
relationship between the unit sample
response in the unit step response one
is the accumulation of the other the
unit step response is the accumulated
response to the unit sample response so
that means that in that previous example
where we saw that setting KT equal to
minus 0.2 resulted in this unit sample
response that would correspond to this
unit step response all you do is for
every sample you calculate for this
response you calculate the sum of say N
equals zero you would take the sum of
all of the previous answers in H of n
it's the accumulation so this it starts
at zero since the sum of all those
numbers is zero then at time one it
becomes the sum from here back so it
becomes 0.2 then here it's the sum from
here back and if you add these all up it
becomes a number that approach
one not surprisingly right if you've got
a feedback system and if you started the
robot up against the wall and the
desired position was about one meter
behind it would monotonically approach
one okay and what you can see is that if
you change the value of the pole here
I've changed the the KT from minus 0.2
which is what the previous answer was to
minus 0.8 I've changed the value of the
pole the unit-sample response got faster
and the unit step response also got
faster it's point is there are different
kinds of performance metrics that we
might want to use unit sample response
unit step response but there are
responses of all of them you can tell
something about the response to all of
them from the response to the unit
sample signal that's why we focus so
much on the unit sample signal it's not
because it's the most popular thing to
use in the lab it's because it's the
easiest thing to calculate with and it
gives us insight into things that we
would like to measure in the lab so for
this very simple system what you can
show is that there's only a few possible
behaviors a few categories of behaviors
if you were to choose KT to be between 0
& 1
then the pole which is 1 plus KT would
also be between 0 & 1 since the system
has a single pole you can say a lot
about the response from the numerical
value of the pole if the pole is between
0 & 1 then the response is going to be
monotonic and converging that results
because the unit sample response was
positive and lean and decayed toward
zero because it's positive only it makes
the step response converge yeah that is
you think positive only means monophonic
goes to 0 makes it converge so you can
infer properties about the unis steps
response from properties of the pole
just like we could infer properties of
the unit-sample response if you changed
Katie to be between -2 and 1 you would
get a peanut that's between minus 1 to 0
again that's just that equation that
says that the response will be
alternating so the sine of the
unit-sample response goes positive and
negative
it still converges in the sense that the
unit-sample response approaches 0 and
what that means for the unit step
response is that the unit step response
will converge toward 1 and it doesn't
the unit step response won't alternate
about this is a sine wound alternating
well I shouldn't say that way the sign
doesn't alternate around 0 the sine
alternates around 1 so again you can
infer the properties of the unit step
response from the properties of the unit
sample response and if you have Katie
that is less than minus 2 then you get a
peanut that's less than minus 1 and
that's a divergent response so the point
is that you can infer properties about
the control system by thinking about the
poles of the system where here I've
Illustrated it for a simple system that
only has one pole ok I told you a bunch
of facts now you figure out something
how would I choose K for this system to
get the quote best performance
so which value of Katie would give the
fastest convergence for the unit sample
signal
okay participation is down but the hit
rate is still good so virtually
everybody who volunteered an answer we
got the right answer
so the most popular answer was - why is
he answer - what's the pot what's the
range of possibilities that we could get
what's the range of Katie that we could
use we could use imaginary numbers
because that doesn't sort of make sense
for a real system but we could choose
sort of any real number the real number
is map according to this chart if the
real numbers map to a different real
number if you choose Katie you can
figure out where is the pole by that
mapping where would you put the pole to
get the fastest response if you have
your choice of putting the pole in
anywhere on this red line that red line
or that red line wherever you put it my
choice of anywhere here and anywhere
here which would you choose
how would you choose it yeah d-roc
is quite cold always converge geography
the basic geometric is the co value so
you'd like the pole to be as small as
possible to get the convergence as fast
as possible that make sense everybody so
in particular for this for this example
if you chose K T T to be minus 1 in that
limit then this entire factor goes away
so the entire response degenerates to R
and R is not instantaneous but it's
pretty fast right what that says is that
you get to the final value in one step
so if the input consisted of a unit
sample which has nonzero value Onias
zero the output would have nonzero value
only at 1 right so thinking about the
way that works in practice so think
about the robot think about we're trying
to drive toward the wall if we made KTB
minus 1 and just for the sake of being
concerned for being concrete let me say
that T is about 1/10 that is that's what
the sampling period is for the robots we
use in the lab if T were 1/10 then the
best K would be minus 10 and what that
says is that if we were one meter away
from where we want to be we would set
the velocity to 10 meters per second
what that says is that if we started 1
meter away from where we want to be so
this dot is intended to represent
position on the same axis that this is
showed so if we started here and we
wanted to be here time has plotted down
if we use the rule that we just
specified then we would set the velocity
given this condition
which is one meter away from where we
want to be we would set the velocity to
be 10 if we set the velocity to be 10
then after 1 unit of time after a tenth
of a second we are 1 meter to the right
which just happens to be exactly where
we want to be had we chosen K to be
bigger we would have overshot have we
chosen K to be smaller we would have
undershot k equals 10 gave us precisely
the right answer so that we get there in
one fell swoop
then on the very next step we would
compute a velocity of zero because where
we are at where we want to be so we
would stay there and that would that
condition would persist forever so the
idea would be this simple system
provides a way that we could set the
game so we could get to where we want to
be in one step it's hard to beat that
the problem that results and the reason
you didn't see that good to behavior in
the lab was that the sensors in the
robot don't work instantaneously they
introduced delay and as an idealization
of that delay I want to think through
the same problem but now let's say that
the sensor delays the input to the
sensor which is the output of the system
let's say that the sensor introduces a
delay of one so now instead of reporting
D sensed which was D not of n it reports
D not of n minus one so now what would
happen now with the delay if I started
here and if by some mysterious process I
am is here at time T N equals 1 then I
would calculate my new velocity what
would be my new velocity here I'm right
where I want to be what would be my new
velocity if I assume that the sensor has
a delay of 1
because the sensor is reporting that I'm
a meter away from where I want to be so
the controller calculates oh I need to
go forward a meter I'll set the velocity
to ten so having set the velocity to ten
and then one step goes by now we're
completely on the wrong side that's what
happens when you put delay into the
system so because we're basing this
decision on where we were last time we
go to the wrong place so now we're here
what were the controllers a nice stay
here you're at a great place right so
I'm really one meter too close in fact I
banged into the wall but the sensor is
telling me I'm exactly where I want to
be so stay here say I didn't kill myself
what will the velocity next be minus 10
so now I tell myself to go back that's
probably a good move but now I still
think I'm close to too close to the wall
so I tell myself to continue to back up
so the idea is that I get poor
performance right the delay had a
devastating effect on the way that the
controller worked even though it's a
tiny change to the way the system works
it has a devastating effect on behavior
so we'd like to be able to predict that
without having to measure it so here's
the same equations except that I've put
a delay in the sensor here's the same
block diagram but I've represented a
delay in the sensor path so now the
question is what's the new functional
representation for that control system
so what's the answer can you write the
functional form for this system as one
of one two three or four or is it none
of the above
the end you can think about reducing the
inner loop the same as we did before and
then think about this as forward over 1
plus loop gain
but now the loop gain has R squared in
it instead of R so we get this form
how's this form differ when the are
wasn't here what's the difference
between are not there and re is there
where
her form was just an R and in this form
is a squared so what's that doe what's
the importance of the fact that there's
a squared there two poles right we now
have a polynomial in the denominator
that is quadratic you know R and what
that's going to do is it's going to give
us two poles instead of one the
importance of that is that now we're
gonna have to think through we we
previously categorized what were all the
behaviors you could get from one pole
the behaviors you could get from one
pole were monotonic divergence non
monotonic alternating divergence
monotonic convergence alternating
convergence so there were four behaviors
that were possible with one pole now we
have to think through what are all the
possible behaviors that we could get
with two poles right different problem
hopefully they're related so here the
way we would find out what the poles are
is take this expression substitute for
every R one over Z turn the pala know
the ratio of polynomials in R into a
ratio of polynomials in Z to do that in
this case I had to multiply numerator
and denominator by Z squared having done
that I get a second second order
polynomial in Z in the bottom so there's
two poles which are the roots of that
polynomial and that's just a quadratic
equation so the interesting thing now is
to map out what are all the possible
behaviors that that system can give us
so it's important to realize that's a
simple generalization of what we saw
before it will be the case that any
system that we construct out of adders
games and delays will have the property
that we can write the system functional
as a ratio of polynomials
are we will be able to buy the factor
theorem we will always be able to factor
the denominator and by the notion of
partial fractions we'll always be able
to write some complicated expression
like that in terms of a sum of parts
each part being first-order so the
intuition we get from this is that what
we ought to do is factor the denominator
find the poles and associate a behavior
with each of those poles so here's what
the problem looks like for the two pole
problem if we have the general form
given here and if we start by thinking
about Katie
being a small having a small magnitude
if Katie has a small magnitude then we
have 1/2 plus or minus the square root
of 1/2 squared so that's 1/2 plus or
minus 1/2 that's 0 or 1 so the poles for
this system if you make K be very small
the poles are at 0 near 0 and near 1 is
that a good system response or a bad
system response near 1 is something near
1/2 the end that never converges right
if you start with some error the error
persists forever well that's not good
right if the if wind turbulence knocks
you into a decline in your airplane and
it persists forever right that's not
good you would like those things to damp
out so this pole is bad how about that
pole
that's good response the decays quickly
but the problem is that when you add the
two pieces together that was the reason
I showed you this decomposition you can
think about the polynomial being
factored and being broken into a number
of parts the part that's associated with
the pole near one has a response that
goes for a long time so that will
asymptotically dominate your response so
we refer to this as a dominant pole this
pole dominates the response that's a way
of inferring behavior of two poles from
us from the sum of single poles right
there's one in this particular case
there's one poll that matters more than
the other one so we call that called the
dominant Pole if you were to make KT
more negative so here's the general form
if you make KT negatives you can make
the thing under the radical sign go
toward zero if you made the thing under
the radical sign go to zero then you
would get to pose at a half that would
happen okay so so here we would see that
if KT remind us a quarter if KT remind
us a quarter we would have half squared
which is plus 1/4 minus 1/4 would give
us zero under the radical so we would
get two poles at 1/2 is that good or bad
associated with the response where the
error gets half what it used to be on
every step so converges if you were to
continue to make K you know if going
from zero to minus 1/4 is good
well then going to minus 1/2 might be
better right if you can continue that
trend say you make KTB minus 1 if KT is
minus 1 then you get 1/2 squared minus 1
so 1/2 squared is 1/4 minus 1 would be
minus 3/4 that gives us a complex pole
pair
so we get two poles that are right on
the unit circle so what's that mean that
means oscillations right oscillations is
something you can't get with one pole
with the real system right oscillations
resolve from a complex from a pole that
has an imaginary component if the system
is real you can only get such a pole you
can only get such poles in pairs so it's
this pair that makes sense for a real
valued system and that gives rise to
oscillations and that's exactly what we
saw here so we can associate the
oscillations that we saw in the
simulated lab experiment with poles that
have imaginary components so what would
be the period of the oscillation in the
system given by 1/2 plus J root 3 over 2
due to previous age if you substitute
minus one
so it's the period of the oscillation in
polar notation the poles we previously
said we're 1/2 plus or minus J root 3
over 2 that's the same as Z plus or
minus J PI over 3 it's easier to use
that form because if you take that form
so if you think about eetu the J or is
it 2 PI over 3 PI over 3 so if you think
about that form that's the pole if we
associate side that X we can write that
that way right then the inside has a
magnitude of 1 so we can think about
that just being a magnitude of 1 and an
angle of PI over 3 so when you raise
that to the N the magnitude to the N 1
to the N is always 1 and the angle
raised to the end it just increases
linearly with n so the angle goes from
PI over 3 to 2 PI over 3 to PI to 4 PI
over 3 etc so you can think about this
going from PI over 3 2 PI over 3 PI 4 5
6
it takes N equals 6 to get around to
where it started so the period is 6 if
you were to further change the gain if
you were to make it even more negative
the poles would go outside the unit
circle and then what would happen
so the point is about changing the game
you can get any behavior on this figure
which is called the root locus so root
meaning the the root of a polynomial
locus meaning the acceptable values of
points so the root locus shows you all
the possible behaviors that could result
from this system so given that root
locus how would you choose K to make
your system response as fast as you
could
so a value of Katie would you want why
would the answer be number two what do
you look at fer properties of the
behavior of the second-order system from
the pole locations we know that there's
an expansion that lets us expand the
system in terms of the sum of two
first-order responses the slowest of the
first-order responses will dominate
eventually so what we need to look at is
the slowest of the two responses so we
would like to know of the two poles
which one is the slowest the slowest is
the one that's closest to the unit
circle so we would get the fastest
response when the slowest one is as fast
as possible so as they as the poles
initially could go toward each other
from 0 to 1 this one is getting faster
this one is getting slower so the
slowest one is this one so they the
slowest one is fastest when they need
and then when they diverge does the
slowest one get faster or slower closer
to the unit circle so you get the
fastest response whenever you get the
two poles both colliding at a 1/2 and
that was the case that happened when
Katie was minus 1/4 from the two or
three slides ago so the idea then is to
try to infer what would be the behavior
of this higher order system by thinking
about the behaviors of the individual
components here the poles and what we
saw was something that's in fact a very
important general trend what we saw was
we first analyzed the wall finder system
assuming there was no delay in the
sensor and we found that that system was
characterized by a single pole and we
had the design freedom of putting that
pole anywhere we wanted to on the real
axis and that allowed us to choose the
pole to be at zero which gave terrific
performance the interesting thing that
happened when you add just one more pole
by putting a delay in the sensor you
make the system more complicated and now
you can't possibly get nearly so good
behavior the behavior is a lot worse
than it was before
and in fact if you were to do this same
kind of analysis by putting yet another
delay in the sensor you would find even
worse behavior so the idea then the
generalization of this the way the
behaviors is working generally speaking
adding delays inside a feedback loop is
a destabilizing thing generally as the
number of delays increases you end up
having to back off on the maximum gain
that you can use because the system
becomes less stable so the the overall
morale is that delays are bad generally
I mean you can concoct some kind of a
weird scheme where that wouldn't be true
but it's actually hard to concoct such a
routine in general and in virtually
every physical system that you run into
adding delays makes the system harder to
stabilize and that's kind of the big
message and the system that we looked at
in the lab the wall finder was actually
quite hard because the number of delays
was large if you try to track where
delays can enter the robot system they
get in at very many different places in
the physical sensor in the
microprocessor in the conversion from
analog to digital there's a number of
delays in that system and that's why it
becomes hard to stabilize ok so that's
the main content for today what I want
to do is give you one more practice
question to think about the problem that
I want you to think of
from today is how do you characterize
performance what we had a single-pole
performance was easy to talk about
because performance was diverging
monotonically diverging alternating
converging monotonically converging
alternating there were four kinds of
behaviors when we went to second order
we saw some new behaviors it could
become oscillatory what I'd like you to
do now is think not just about those
properties but many other properties so
here's some questions think about the
system on the top and I'd like you to
infer properties about that system in
particular does this system have three
poles is the unit-sample response is
there a way to write that as the
geometrics as the sum of three geometric
sequences what's the unit-sample
response and is one of the poles that z
who's wanting it so think about the
system think about five ways of
characterizing it and tell me how many
of those five characterizations is
correct
so how many of the properties are true
how many Poles how do you get three
so take this thing and we would rewrite
that with our goes to one over Z so we
get one over Z cubed 1 over 1 minus Z
cubed which is then clearing the Z cubes
we get 1 over Z cubed minus 1 how many
Poles
3 what are the poles of Z cubed minus 1
three small one so that's good let's hey
bucks there's two poles and z-one yes No
why not
so there's three Falls so imagine
playing where's the poles well you could
factor it right if you factored it you
would find that there is a pole one
right
but then there's two more poles like
that right so the poles are the three
roots of one right which can be written
like one e to the J 2 PI over 3 and e to
the J minus 2 PI over 3 which po is the
dominant Pole
okay bad question what's a better
question how many dominant culture
that's a much better question yes
there's sort of three fold that are
equally dominant right they all have the
same magnitude what's it why why do we
talk about domina poles what are domina
poles good for well we can write this
thing's we can write this response as
something that looks like three to the N
plus minus 1 to the N if you let n get
big enough the only one that matters is
3 to the N so if all you care about is
exactly how the plane was flying the
incident before he hit the ground then
you would only need to worry about long
time and if you only worry about long
time you only need to worry about the
pole that's worst behaved right that's
where the concept comes from so none of
these poles are particularly worse
behaved than the others right
what's the unit-sample response
associated with that pole
we're gonna name for that what's the
unit-sample response associated with
this poll with that poll is e to the J 2
PI over 3 and right so that's a complex
number so that's one at time 0 and e to
the J 2 PI over 3 and at time 1 and e to
the J 4 PI over 3 and at time 2 so it
goes from here at 0 to here at 1 to here
at 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
what's the period of the of this poll
what's the period of the unit-sample
response associated with that poll 3
because it takes 3 to get around to
where you started again what's the
period of this
so the point so what's the period of
this poll question so period-wise regime
right if the response repeats its on
time then when we say the response is
periodic okay that response is neither
of those polls well-known the minus one
is that is the minus one poll periodic
yes right because the response
alternated in sign the unit-sample
response of one poll that word the poll
is a negative number
alternated in sign so we gave that a
name right alternation is not
necessarily something that we would like
to associate with a higher order system
periodic is perfectly reasonable to talk
about for a higher order system periodic
merely means that if Y of n were a
periodic signal then I could express Y
of n plus n as Y event that would be
periodic right if the thing repeats
itself we would say it's periodic so the
point of going over this stuff is just
to give you some exercise in thinking
about how to think about properties of
systems right we develop properties
initially thinking about one pole those
properties were easy
converging-diverging monotonic
alternating when we try to apply when we
try to think about corresponding
properties of higher order systems we
can't simply map the simple properties
the first order systems into the other
we have to think about more complicated
things then we think about things like
dominant if one of the poles has a
bigger magnitude than the other then for
large times we can ignore the smaller
one so
what happens for short time is it the
case does this response monotonically
increase with time for all time and
close to zero that can be just as
important as this one so the alternation
property you you the dominant pole idea
tells you how things work when you have
large times it doesn't necessarily tell
you how things work when you have small
times how about the unit-sample response
is the sum of 3 Jam geometrics yes or
not
that's very important right the two
teams over here are this pole to the n
plus to this pole to the n plus
something that goes with this other pole
to the N now it's a weighted sum but the
weights are not necessarily zero right
so the slide that I showed you for the
partial fraction decomposition you can
always write a higher order system as a
sum of first order factors that's the
partial fraction expansion that doesn't
mean the weights are all unity so number
two can you write the unit-sample
response to the sum of three geometric C
signals
yes there it is and if you really go to
complex math you can find out a B and C
and that we tell you the unit-sample
response and now we tell you the answer
two three and four is the unit-sample
response to 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 1 or 1
0 0 1 1 whatever is it one of those two
or something different
I came out here he said UNICEF response
he's not a food correct is he requests
units and 1 0 1 0 0 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 1
yes how do you know that you could in
fact you can see it in the network if
any about the difference equation would
be easy thinking about the network would
be easy and if we think about the
unit-sample response to this thing
started is at rest rest means this is 0
this is 0 and this is 0 initially unit
sample response means this is becomes 1
at time 0 at time 0 this is 1 this is 0
this is 0 this is 0 right so if I think
about what's the time response to look
like
and I did plus so this is one zero zero
zero so the first answer is zero clock
ticks what happens so this one this one
this doesn't change that doesn't change
this goes to zero zero comes around here
that goes to zero so that's the answer
at time one mmm what happens at time two
one this goes to zero these stay zero
this stays zero that's the answer at
time equal to now the clock ticks now
this comes over to here that means it
comes back here this is still zero that
comes to one that's the answer for time
three now the clock ticks and you can
see the whole thing will just repeat
itself now is the response periodic yeah
there's periodic what's a period right
this period is three this periods three
this period is just one if you want to
call that a period but they are related
okay so the point of this exercise is to
show to illustrate two things we've
inferred properties of first-order
systems by looking at a single pole
which for a real system could only
behave in one of four different ways
second-order system introduced new
behaviors now we can oscillate which we
couldn't do before having got two
oscillation oscillation came about
because of complex numbers if we go to
higher order systems nothing new happens
in algebra right complex numbers there
doesn't there's no such thing as meta
complex numbers right complexes as bad
as it gets so you can have complex
numbers the higher order behaviors can
still have complex numbers that you have
to think when we ask you what's the
property of a higher
system you can think about it in terms
of the individual parts but it requires
some thinking okay good luck tonight sue
that